when working together as a couple or
friends or business partners what are
the do's and don'ts like they always say
don't go to bed angry or if you do go to
bed angry apologize in the morning use
constructive criticism or you know be
soft and your delivery of any kind of
ridicule what can you reckon well we
like to go to bed angry yes we never
apologize um and there's not really
concerned about how he feels or what he
thinks I'm more concerned about not
looking like we're fighting in front of
other people that's not yes mm-hmm um
but for a serious answer what would you
say it's hard it's a challenge
especially because you know we work out
of our home so there's that sort of
there's no differentiation from there's
no clocking out yeah so so it's hard
it's a challenge but you have to make
time for the relationship you have to
make time to separate and unplug and go
on a vacation which we haven't done one
time yeah more even than vacation 11
years one weekend yes not counting
family vacation isn't that sort of thing
um yeah so you just have to get up you
try to keep it as separate as you can
and you know I mean it's not gonna work
in every relationship and I've had
people say you're crazy maybe they're
right I don't know but we get to be
together 24 hours a day and she's my
best friend um dos equis please ah so it
is it is lovely to you know because we
both had the day jobs where we go off
and we're both away from the house for
you know ten hours a day and come home
you see each other for just a little bit
so it is really nice to be like oh she's
over there working on the computer and
I'm working on my computer and sometimes
it doesn't seem like it's the best of
times when it you're really stressed or
whatever but but I think we'll look back
on this time and really appreciate it
it's also nice um if you're a
non-confrontational sort of person in
other relationships in other working
relationships you know things can build
up but you know we have a very solid
history and relationship so we can
say no you're wrong and you don't have
to worry about all that other stuff and
patting it or what or massaging it like
you would with someone else why so
there's less of a filter right con ESP
yeah which can get you into trouble
sometimes but it's also I think honesty
really is important in the collaborative
relationship and plus you can laugh
about the same things because you're
commiserate over something that didn't
go through because you're both in it to
get writers write some people maybe
their partners doing something else and
they never see them so right neither of
us were smart enough to find a civilian
with a real job that could pay the bill
that's the problem or nothing to do yes
find a banker or someone like that that
helped you subsidize your art
you